finally it is war time the fourth
shinobi war to be specific but before i
dive into the review for this week i
regretfully need to announce something
as many of you might have noticed or saw
either on twitter or as the pinned
comment in last week's video i revealed
that i had in fact been spoiled on one
significant aspect of the story that
being i now know who madara really is
despite using the same tactics i had
been using with one piece muting words
on various social media as it happened
the spoilers came by way of a much more
malicious source during the flame war on
twitter last week regarding the great
sakura debate someone went out of their
way to spell names with numbers to slip
through my muted words intentionally in
an effort to specifically spoil me now i
want this experience to be as authentic
as i possibly can so i felt it necessary
to be transparent about this i'm sorry
if this has dampened anyone's excitement
for the rest of this series and my
reactions but i'll be taking more
extreme measures to avoid more instances
like this in the future that said i am
still very excited to see how the rest
of the story pans out and intent on
sharing my thoughts on obito's reveal
once it does prop up in the story often
times it's the hows and whys that are
the most interesting narratively anyway
and so with that somewhat somber
disclaimer out of the way it's time to
dive into something a little more
action-packed and fun as i said in the
beginning this video is about war so
let's get to it
off the back of my last video i'm
picking things up again right as naruto
save sakura from her second near-death
experience courtesy of sasuke which
leads to a surprisingly novel experience
in the series there is a standoff yes
but there is relatively speaking very
little action with only one blob being
exchanged between the two warriors and
the interesting part of this scene
doesn't come from the action but instead
through the thoughts and words shared
yeah but first a quick word from our
sponsor
thank you so much to athletic greens for
sponsoring today's video they were kind
enough to send across their wonderful
comprehensive all-in-one greens powder
called ag-1 by athletic greens for me
this is a year all about restoring the
active lifestyle i largely lost during
the past few years of madness in the
world i have plans to travel the us this
year and also run a marathon there's a
lot to do that requires me to feel as
healthy as possible so joining up with
athletic greens was a real no-brainer
their ag-1 powder makes keeping up with
the nutrition super simple no longer do
you need to keep up with a whole bunch
of different tablets to maintain your
health 75 vitamins minerals whole foods
source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens that's a mouthful all of this
contained within one single daily
serving it's totally brainless and has
gone a long way in not only helping me
feel a boost in energy throughout the
day but has also helped me bounce back
quicker from my daily workouts if this
sounds good then you'll be glad to hear
athletic greens have also been kind
enough to offer you guys a whole year's
free supply of vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
for me one of the best aspects is that
ag-1 is super simple to use you just mix
one scoop with water or your favorite
smoothie or juice of choice shake it up
and you're good to go it's got a fairly
earthy taste with a sweet edge the
intensity of which is really easy to
control based on how much liquid you use
and of what type which is great for
someone like me who's always a bit
skeptical of healthy looking green
things so if that sounds good to you be
sure to click the link in the
description now to get your year supply
of vitamin d3 k2 and 5 travel packs for
free with your first purchase ag-1
provides your body with everything it
needs for optimal performance every
single day this is a game changer for
supporting your immune system and i
can't recommend it enough
naruto sees sasuke as a friend and
understands the nuance of his situation
he's also capable of empathizing with
his circumstances even going as far as
to imagine a scenario where he could
have turned out exactly the same as
sasuke lost and vengeful there's a nice
callback to their last major conflict
with naruto himself citing that they are
both high-level shinobi now meaning they
should be able to read each other's
thoughts apparently further emphasizing
this sense in sasuke that naruto does in
fact understand why he is the way that
he is and
drags to the forefront sasuke's mistakes
for him only for sasuke to double down
on his path moments afterwards by
requesting he receive his brother's eyes
because he is now losing his vision and
speaking of which perhaps down the road
this choice could act as a physical
embodiment of finally getting to see the
world from his brother's perspective
slowly coming around to his way of
seeing things both literally and
metaphorically in other words there
might be a chance for some nice albeit
slightly on the nose symbolism but i
digress the scene itself between sasuke
and naruto exchanging words has some
really nice callbacks to their
respective pasts as they launch towards
each other with their respective
signature techniques the chidori and the
rasengan it's quite tense and despite it
being for the most part a little teaser
or prelude to what will no doubt be a
massive conflict later on in the story i
thought the dialogue and themes
presented here were both entertaining
and effective in what they were trying
to achieve and before i move on i want
to touch on what might be a minor visual
cue but it might also be my favorite
visual indicator during the entire
confrontation that spoke to how serious
and all in really naruto was during this
meeting with sasuke prior to stepping
forward to confront him both physically
and verbally naruto had created two
other clones this could have created the
perfect situation for him to hedge his
bets and bluff by keeping his true self
back while sending out a clone to carry
out that same message you know for
safety however and this speaks to what
he said to sakura about authenticity and
being true to oneself he didn't do that
as made evident by those two clones
vanishing the moment sasuke leaves
revealing that the real naruto was in
fact the one in front of him all along
before passing out in that moment he
really put everything on the line
extending a friendly smile and genuine
hand in order to potentially save his
friend earnestly trying to do so that's
a powerful statement and it's
communicated without words brilliantly
in a way only naruto the character can
it's a brilliant part of this scene that
honestly was quite understated i thought
switching gears now to something
completely different killer bee returns
to his village with his brother in tow
the reikage since defeating kasami he's
been keeping his sword as a quote spoil
of war but oh wait
kisame is alive this legitimately caught
me off guard i genuinely thought he was
dead considering the direction the story
was going it made sense to me at the
time that the cast would start to
dwindle down some however my estimation
was entirely incorrect instead we're not
only not killing off kisame but we're
reincorporating him back into the story
along with kabuto with a brand new
snake-like design and speaking of kabuto
i'm glad orochimaru's presence is still
being felt in this story since his
absorption somewhat so much time had
been spent on him and his desires as a
character furthermore he offered a
really interesting third position in the
akatsky versus shinobi war that's now
looming on the horizon and thankfully
kabuto can act as the replacement for
that ideology in many respects with his
desires not necessarily interfering with
the akatsuki the alliance between the
two was an interesting one for sure and
catching back up with the kanoa folks
that sakura knocked out i think it's
interesting watching karen remark on
what she feels when looking at naruto
compared to when she looked at sasuke
remarking that he's the exact opposite
of him bright and warm but what i really
liked about this was what it was
foreshadowing for moments after she
remarks on his brightness and warmth she
comes right out and remarks on what
darkness lies beneath the nine-tailed
fox spirit i'd like this in retrospect
as it really helps to set up and build
up a challenge naruto eventually has to
face mastering this darkness he
possesses deep down and speaking of that
darkness right off the back of sasuke's
successful eye surgery transplant or
whatever you want to call it we witness
an encounter between naruto and the toad
spirits this largely deals with the
elder toad examining naruto's destiny
for any signs of progression towards a
favorable goal in it he sees two
entities in naruto's future the toad
elder sees an octopus taking the form of
a mentor of which while reading i had a
few working theories as to what that
eight lint entity might manifest as
theory number one octopuses are famous
for their eight limbs limbs which look
like tails and so my first thought is
that this could easily point to naruto
being mentored by killer bee and his
eight-tail spirit this makes sense as he
would be able to teach him to control
the nine tails like he did with his
eight as established earlier in the
story this one happened to be correct
theory number two was maybe the octopus
and his eight limbs are a misdirect and
naruto is actually going to fight
against or learn from kabuto and his
mini snakes which could take the form of
eight snakes who knows this was a long
shot and i knew it and finally my third
theory was maybe the octopus is a
metaphor for a beast composed of eight
individuals maybe this will result in
naruto working with killerby and seven
others to complete his training but this
again was a long shot in my eyes the
second and final prophecy interpreted by
the toad spoke of someone whose power
lies in his eyes which naruto
confidently alludes to sasuke matching
that description and i mean it does but
now that naruto and effectively
kishimoto has pointed it out it makes me
question whether or not it is going to
be sasuke either way i'm excited by the
prospects of this i love that this
training naruto has to undergo also
forces him to focus on what makes him
different from sasuke that his training
is only possible because he represents
the ideological opposite to sasuke's
hatred one cannot master what naruto is
setting out to do by embracing hate but
in fact suppressing and overcoming it
it's perfect and the means with which he
does it is also great right now naruto
has to overcome his internal demons to
even qualify for the training under
killer bee and upon stepping up to this
preliminary challenge naruto realizes
what's being asked of him the actual
manifestation of his anger resentment
and hatred stands before him the chakra
and world that naruto inhabits is great
for these obvious visual metaphors and
often times when shows have interesting
worlds and settings like this that lend
a lot to their stories they rest in the
laurels of those advantages while not
staying true to the characters in this
however the manifestation of naruto's
hatred is perfectly in keeping with his
character earlier in the arc as well as
other times in this series naruto's been
apprehensive to indulge or fully embrace
the adulation he's been receiving since
becoming the hero of kanoa and when
faced with his inner hatred we learn
that this stems from a lack of trust in
them and himself a lack of trust because
he doesn't fully believe in himself
being worthy of this praise and there's
something beautiful about that once he
overcomes it not through action but
instead through self-acceptance and this
early training material is full of
moments very true to naruto's character
he's lighthearted in the face of
uncertainty and would offer the chance
to use a clone to hedge his bets he
unflinchingly refuses to use it citing
that he's going to trust himself
speaking again to that very aspect
present in the last encounter with
sasuke that i loved so much
the struggle between naruto and the
nine-tailed fox spirit is for all
intents and purposes one of the best
moments for me in the entire series not
just for its thematic resonance with me
or even how well it's drawn there's tons
to love and appreciate about this
sequence and struggle for naruto with
his clear reliance and every signature
move he's learned across the series from
the clone technique to the rosengan to
even the sage mode itself all of which
are manifestations and results derived
from those that have helped and loved
him in the past particularly with the
sage mode and when he uses that i
actually got chills all of this is
fantastic however for me the best part
of this scene came from how it ended up
making me feel
at the beginning of every volume
kishimoto writes a short paragraph
describing either the development of
this particular volume or whatever might
have been on his mind at the time of
writing it for volume 53 he wrote this
when the time came to put together the
plot for naruto volume 53 i consulted my
wife and this is what resulted stories
about mother and if i'm being completely
honest i really felt that warm authentic
motherly influence all over these
chapters when naruto contends with his
inner demons the fact that his mother
and father were both set up by prior
seals to appear at certain key moments
in his life i thought was a brilliant
touch there's a scene much later on
where iruku's father says to him it's
the parents duty to protect their
children and protect their child kushina
and minato most definitely did and
continue to do culminating with the
events detail from chapter 500 onwards
entitled the birth of naruto this is the
best part of the story i've read i don't
think i've ever been more captivated by
this series before the sense of occasion
spectacle and profound drama coats each
and every page enticing me to read
further the precise and careful steps
taken by madura to exact his revenge on
kanoa by unleashing the nine-tailed fox
spirit the sheer scale of the occasion
knowing what we do now about what
happens all the while we watch as
naruto's mom and dad do everything in
their power to hang on long enough to
save him and his village it's a stunning
series of chapters that i actually found
myself going back over to read before
writing this very section of the video
it's just so well handled with the small
cameos from kakashi and guy with irika
being courageous even as early as then
we get to see the third hokage as well
as a host of other villagers and shinobi
some familiar and others formerly slain
but beyond anything else the real star
of this show is the sense of paternal
responsibility intense love for and
belief in their first and only child
naruto i love how natto is so
level-headed calm and talented always
looking to put the needs of his family
and others ahead of his own and i adore
how chaotic and courageous kushina is
when trying to help her husband and
child i can see clear as day where all
of naruto's best traits came from the
drama and stakes rise higher and higher
until they both realize that there's
only one way of dealing with this
monster and when they come to that
conclusion naruto's father exclaims
let's believe in this child he is our
son after all for a series like naruto i
don't think there could have been a more
fitting line than this right here a
child that has suffered from a feeling
of inadequacy because he felt no one
ever believed in him because no one ever
loved him ended up in that situation for
quite the opposite reason because those
that loved him more than anything else
in the world were willing to lay
everything they had on the line to save
him to believe in his future and what he
can bring to the world it's such a
brilliant line that speaks to the 500
chapters that came before it and then
there's the final moments of the volume
where kushina and minato moments before
their respective deaths unpack
everything they wish they could tell
their son before they pass on and to say
that i wept in these fleeting moments
would be an understatement this utterly
destroyed me and i cannot express just
how much i adore this scene today and it
was all down to how authentic it felt
remaining true to the mission statement
at the beginning of this volume i can
absolutely tell that kishimoto and his
wife collaborated on the dialogue and
direction of these scenes cushina had so
much to say she was so loving and
maternal both in a traditional sense and
in a progressive one of times all the
while monato remained steadfast kind and
supportive all the way to the bitter end
it's fantastically believable and
entrancing in the most tragic and
beautiful of ways easily the most
emotional this series has made me hands
down no exceptions with the final
results being a newly unlocked form the
likes of which is more aesthetically
pleasing to me than any other design
i've yet seen produced from naruto or
kishimoto for the rest of this series it
looks powerful transcended and
appropriately angelic given what naruto
has gone through to achieve it it looks
perfectly suited to naruto himself as
karen would put it bright
[Music]
guy versus kisame so this fight scene
boasts one of the few moments that
actually made me laugh out loud while
reading a manga having already
established what happened at the
waterfall of truth through naruto's
fight with himself to contrast that with
kisame crashing through it leading to
guy believing that kisame's weird spiky
crazy form was his true self gave me a
good chuckle in all honesty and
furthermore i was elated that guy was
now back in the fold actively
participating in the story it's been way
too long and i hope we get to see more
of rockley and him too those characters
are way too good not to be used more
than they currently are and in all
seriousness this fight vindicates that
desire because holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
this was incredible throughout this
series kisame has been a cockroach not
in the sense that he's an irritating
insect but more so that he just won't
die or go away and being incredibly
powerful as he is he's always been a
large issue whenever he's propped up in
the story armed with abilities that
absorb chakra i honestly couldn't think
of a better opponent to absolutely body
him like guy did right here the years of
tireless practice in perfecting an area
of fighting that's been somewhat
neglected in modern times taijutsu
something that could have been seen as a
weakness in some other occasion is the
very reason he was able to overcome
kisame in this moment there's no chakra
use at all he's just so powerful his
fists changed the pressure in the air
enough to create this monstrosity
watching kisame try and fail to secure
any of his chakra in his usual way it's
mind-bendingly cool to watch and when
kisame tries to move even an inch
afterwards guy pounces on him
effortlessly pinning him to the ground
yet again for an individual who's more
flamboyant and lighthearted than most it
serves his character and indeed this
scene well for him to be so serious
during this encounter it's a great
contrast what a tussle so damn cool also
i'm not gonna lie there are times when
i'm reading the story that i wished it
was more like guy and rock lee's story
they need their own spin-off manga or
something because i would read that in a
heartbeat
i just love their designs and characters
they're just so dorky while also looking
effortlessly badass when drawn a certain
way that's a really tough balance to
strike with the design and they're
barely used at all the ending however of
this encounter with kisame is actually
kind of nice but in a troubling sort of
way of course trying to get intel from
kisame while he's down kisame elects to
off himself instead of relinquishing
said information and i like this really
only because we get a short glimpse into
his past and his first introduction to
hitachi way back when i will however say
that i would have liked this backstory
to be established a little earlier in
the story than it was right now us being
filled in on the details of his key life
thematic moments mere seconds before his
death feels a tiny bit rushed and i feel
cheapens the overall character he's a
brilliant character this sort of felt
like kishimoto was a kid in class doing
his homework right before it started
though i suppose that's a bit severe
we've known kisame for quite some time
and i still very much enjoyed this bit
of introspection it offered us for
hitachi and indeed how it influenced
kasami's judgment i especially liked the
line attached to others about death
quote no matter who you are you do not
know what kind of human you are until
the very end which speaks wonderfully to
both hitachi and indie kisame's death at
this moment i really like this inclusion
[Music]
is
and right off the back of kisame we get
this mammoth of a battle between conan
and uchiha madhura during which his mass
starts to break off from her incredible
attack and will to defeat him i didn't
see this battle in the anime but in the
manga the scale and scope of kishimoto's
drawings really sold me on the magnitude
of this encounter conan is standing up
for an ideal instilled in her by naruto
earlier in the story hopeful that the
future nagato yearned for would
eventually become a reality it's clear
that obito or madura in this instance is
single-minded in his approach referring
to nagato initially not by name but
instead by his utility the rinigun and
watching conan shroud him in her bombs
leaving him with a destroyed mask and a
missing arm felt massively satisfying
and surprising it seems having come from
a group that believed in yahiko or
nagato being the bridge to peace they
now have only one hope left naruto and
really i think that's a nice build up
towards the climax there's a really
sweet little sign off too to these
characters using their time spent with
jarya but again i kind of wish this
lesson they shared wasn't established
for the purposes of this exit to the
story i still think it's massively
resonant but i think it could have been
made a lot more effective if it had been
a callback to an element of their
training we had already been exposed to
during their time with jiraiya but
that's honestly just a small gripe and
hey look moderator has a swanky new mask
right at this moment naruto thinks he's
on a mission to count the amount of
balls on these animals all the while not
daedara and kabuto
tried to reach and capture him while
flying on a giant clay bird which is in
and of itself flying to an island that
is also not an island but a massive turf
do i have that right this story is so
weird and i love it in the best of ways
at this point the story is escalating
much faster than i expected it to which
is brilliant from a pacing standpoint
and i love the atmosphere and characters
that are being brought to the forefront
of this arc too funnily enough kishimoto
wrote at the beginning of volume 55 that
he had to go back and reference his
older work because this upcoming section
involved so many past characters
apparently he just forgot about their
specs and don't worry kishimoto so did i
probably the most significant actions
that occurred during this encounter were
that the old kage guide that looks a
little like the inspiration for gran
torino from my hero academia fought
against adara and of course the capture
of yamato by kabuto i think the most
interesting part of this for me was how
calculated and measured kabuto's
judgment seems to be in this instance
he's not going to overextend himself at
all and due to that he's managed to make
off with yamato a massively powerful
shinobi and ally to naruto all in an
effort to effectively fuel matara's army
and i guess that means
it's time for war
[Applause]
[Music]
gara's speech
one thing i will say about this from the
outset as it's as good a time as any to
say it gara's ruined the story ever
since the time skip has been diminished
so significantly that it almost feels
like an injustice similar to how i've
expressed myself concerning gaian rock
lee gaara is another one of those
characters i felt could have offered so
much more to the story having been get
another albeit much more simple analog
to sasuke given the journey he's on
right now i was prepared going into the
time skip for gara to fulfill a specific
role while not as prominent as naruto
and sasuke i figured given his standing
in the story at the time that he would
have been kept involved in the rat race
so to speak with that said leading up to
this point i haven't been entirely upset
with his utility in the tale altogether
he does provide an interesting bit of
commentary concerning his view on the
old guard versus the next generation and
i do like how he empathizes from time to
time on the actions of different
characters he relates to on a deeper
level furthermore i think placing him
into a leader's role is a really
interesting idea and while i am happy
with what he offers the story i think
he's still being criminally
underutilized and i'd even go as far as
to say that i feel like there have been
some new characters introduced in the
second half of the story fulfilling
roles that he could have otherwise been
occupying at this moment but that's just
my opinion as we're introduced to both
the shinobi and the akatsky forces
there's a great contrast established
while we look at the folks fighting on
behalf of shinobi against the akatsuki
we see numerous faces some familiar some
unfamiliar all with a strong sense of
character perspective and experience or
lack thereof every one of them voices
their concerns speculations and thoughts
to us as we cycle through each regiment
however with the akatsuki there's
nothing but darkness and silence like an
army of zombies totally void of life are
bracing themselves for an imminent
attack awaiting the orders of their
leader modera it's quite tense and
atmospheric from being perfectly honest
[Music]
gara's speech is the best thing his
character has done since naruto saved
him so so long ago and while i have my
grievances with how this character has
been treated since this scene still
speaks to the aspects of the character
that i adored back in the beginning and
indeed still do right now the
differences that make up this fighting
unit this army when compared to the
forces of the akatsuki is that of life
they aren't resurrected beings they
aren't zombies they have one life and
they have free will these are the very
things that they are fighting against
the akatsuki for however they are also
something that at this moment are
standing in their respective ways for
many years the shared histories of these
villages mist cloud sandstone leaf etc
have been a source of pain and hatred
for one another but this is where gara
has a chance to utilize his unique
history to act as the great unifier in
many respects and in quite spectacular
fashion too might i add i was only
sitting here reading the speech in the
manga and it still gave me chills again
he totally empathizes with the
respective points of view and even
offers himself up to the chopping block
once this is all over but also outlines
that today they need to unify using
their shared experience with the
akatsuki to understand that this is much
larger than each of them and their
individual feelings right now and serves
to highlight that following hatred is a
recipe for disaster a lesson naruto
taught him and for naruto their families
and their homes they must fight this day
it's a spectacular speech that again
speaks to the themes of this character
and indeed to handing over
responsibility to the next generation to
try and make amends for the mistakes of
the
past like i mentioned in the past with
regards to naruto's motivation and
conviction as well as what's highlighted
when comparing these two armies a
driving force of many of these conflicts
is that of dealing with reality and
right here in this battle we see just
that we watch his side confronts a
version of his brother who he loves we
watch as cesari learns to understand
that the so-called true self he now
believes he is is nothing more than a
marionette controlled and conjured by
someone else all of these are terrific
instances that speak to the ideology
that makes for the real battleground
that this all is taking place on with a
really nice touch being that of their
termination not by offense but instead
by convincing them to join reality
instead of a fantasy a nice ruffle in
the story from kishimoto i thought and
if the impending battle was intense
enough the training naruto's undergoing
right now might yield my new favorite
technique in this series so this biju
chakra fire spirit mode he's got right
now is surprisingly similar mechanically
to that of the kaioken well at least
from what it offers the story in some
important respects similar to the
kaioken if goku were to rely too heavily
on it it would cease being a tool and
instead become an instrument for his
demise as seen during the saiyan saga
however with naruto having successfully
alphaed the ninetail spirit he now has
access to the fox's chakra reserves an
important and brilliant addition to his
repertoire however without having tamed
the fox naruto now runs a very large
risk if he relies too heavily on the fox
spirit's chakra energy the fox too can
steal naruto's chakra and if that
supplier reaches zero that being
naruto's chakra energy then there's no
more naruto and to add more weight to
this issue if he uses the clone
technique it expedites that same process
which not only means a significantly
important technique fundamental to much
of his arsenal has now been compromised
but he also can't lean as heavily on it
to speed up his training but in typical
naruto fashion this isn't going to slow
the young man down but i honestly have
no idea where this will lead him my hope
is somewhere really cool i'm going to
stop here for now next time i cover
naruto i will be covering all the
upcoming battles and i hope i'll see you
there if you want more content like this
consider subscribing it makes a massive
difference to myself and my team and it
only takes two seconds of your time and
hey you can always undo it later if you
want with all of that said i hope you
have a terrific day i've been totally
not mark and thank you all so much for
watching
[Music]
you